une production du studio sf mais amenés
au sans fil présentée par chris miller
podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut nous
d'acheter avec moi de me plante pour
tous vos besoins un casque sur d'autres
téléphones ordinateurs utilisés notre
code promo sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais sur toutes les commandes caisse
me puis à chaque commande en fait vous
allez contribuer à planter des heures
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques
donc rendre l'utile à l'agréable
évidemment d'hommes cette semaine sur le
podcast cette semaine on reçoit une
femme politique inspirant qui s'appelle
catherine fournit une femme qui veut
faire les choses différemment qu'ils
veulent qui peut révolutionner puis
rendre la politique moins partisane
moins et moins plate - oui la chicane
plaque noté vian quelqu'un qui veut
changer les choses
que faire avancer les dossiers pour le
bien de tous pour le bien de la société
et qui était députée indépendante ou
provincial équipe russe qui se présente
à la mairie de longueuil gatineau
économie catherine fournis par contador
[Musique]
catherine fournier qu'on a parlé on a
fait un tour de l'actualité des enjeux
qui lui tiennent à coeur qu'elle a
défendus avec des motions l'assemblée
nationale vraiment c'était super
parlophone puis aussi de ckoi sa vision
pour longueuil
c'est quoi sa vision pour la politique
pour pour notre société
une philosophie d'agir locales pour
changer au final le monde alors ce sport
spa c'est toujours un plaisir par les
critiques
alors merci beaucoup on est revenu sur
sur les constats poste que viennent
ensuite post post pandémie fait que je
perds intéressant on va les remercier
nos commanditaires avant de blesser à la
conversation fait que blick le podcast
cette semaine et présenté par nos amis
chez même skate qui font les produits
ultime pour l'entretien sous la ceinture
ils viennent tout juste de sortir le
lendemain 4.0 qui a les mêmes figures
que le lendemain ou 3.0 c'est à dire la
technologie pour pas vous [ __ ] les
couilles
le roi le plus sûr que les y ont ajouté
plusieurs grandes heures de garde donc
si vous voulez pas devenir un petit peu
style en faire des petites formes dans
soient vos poils sous la ceinture et de
l'armée même pour le visage en fait fait
tout seul en plus ce contrat volokh fait
que ce n'est pas chez quai dans vos
bagages
ultra simple puis viennent de lancer
aussi le ultra semi baquets musharraf en
sa propre eau à être plus mous que ce
cessez-le le snes ultime dans ce package
le toit le crop chèvres qui est un grand
joueur mais tire au regard comme ce à
trois lames pour aller dans tous les
recoins et possibles imaginables de la
région
des bijoux de famille et avec ce il ya
des produits qui n'avait que ça on a le
crom gel donc un petit jet l'arrosage
pour se mettre sur pied pour que pour
que ça aille le plus loin possible
encore une fois et l'europe exfolie et
heures petit exfoliant qu'on se bat
après pour soi d'où doudou c'est
incroyable c'est doux c'est magnifique
on peut pas recommander les pros du
masque est passé fake jugez par vous
même en utilisant notre code promo sans
filtre pour 20% de rabais et le shipping
gratuit sur tous leurs produits fait
qu'aller voir sa fille mercy la gamme
genesis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis sûrement de certaines entrevues
légendaire aussi de tout le monde en
parle de ces vingt dernières années y en
a pas eu tant que ça mais quand nous on
était plus jeune je me rappelle d ici là
fort pas de bon sens qui s'est passé sur
le plateau puis comme ça s'est perdu un
peu on se rappelle quand je te rends
dany est parti on est vraiment trop peu
tout le monde en parle dans le fond ça a
été super marque un camp d'été j'ai
effectivement ouais je sais comment on a
revu ces parties a fait ça vaut bien la
photo reçue ça fait un an quasiment jour
pour jour dans le fond la france mais on
attend on en est en jaune par exemple
puis quelle année ce fut quand même
cette année le freemont est ce que
ti vct la 1ère mettons qu'on serait pas
au besoin à ce que tu aurais pu imaginer
que ça allait se passer de même parce
que l'on venait de cloisonner chez nous
le tout avec cette surprise autant que
tout le monde sérieusement j'ai le
profil plus est positive mais rappelle
justement d'un victor l'année dernière
de commencer ça va bien quand même au
québec un souci on était vraiment dans
la phase commerces et même tout nouveau
tout beau tout va bien on encourage le
cas pas démenti le gouvernement avait
quand même très bien et bien perçu bien
c'est bien reçu le premier je savais pas
encore donc sincèrement non je
m'entendais peut donc bien malin est
celui qui aurait pu se douter aussi que
tu avais aussi longtemps que je mange
donc c'est quand il ya eu le dit
confinement par la cites en mi juin des
résurgences cet automne mais c'était
avec quelqu'un qui nous avait dit que en
septembre en octobre tout fermerait à
nouveau et que ce serait vraiment plus
long que la dernière fois et jusqu'à
couvre-feu était long ça fait depuis le
mois de janvier andré incroyable cette
source
c'est incroyable il ya exactement ce
commentaire je te laisse je me prenais
jeter comme crise il ya un couvre-feu
qui avait pour moi un couvre feu de type
le jeu voyait jouer le monde qui
commençait à rentrer parce qu'ils
étaient rendus devant quoi j'ai montré
que je me réveillais pour la première
fois à faire en sachant que ça ça
finissait je me rêvais pour la première
fois face c'est fou ce qu'on a vécu les
cct à 20 qu'il confinement se fasse
j'avais même pas que c'était possible
moi je n'aime pas que c'est une option
j'avoue confinement le connais comme une
balance
c'est quelque chose qui se pouvait le
type qu'on nous dise à tout
toute une société toute la planète vous
sortez pas on ferme tout
cfoot est jamais être quand c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont annoncés c'était comme si
on propose croire comme trop proche des
événements comme la par rapport au
couvre-feu ont le juste c'est tes les
gens suivront vu justement d intégrer
serrer les rangs de ses banques et on va
faire ce qu'on a fermé t on va en parler
longtemps chez nous c'est tellement ils
n'étaient on va raconter ça à nos
petits-enfants pis il y avait un
couvre-feu dans le temps des confins
devient monte grappa par andorre toi
t'es rendu complètement fou quand on
parle de consulter au moins dans l'excès
c'est quand même
renversant qu'on a vécu mais c'est
absolument rien de comparable tu sais
dans notre confort quand même toutes ont
été très chanceux une puce wi et des
contraintes il y venir à son issue
savate un cataclysme écologique fac du
jeu onéreux sweet spot avec la planète
seulement la population avait annoncé
puis c'est quoi un arbre n'existe plus
c'est avec qui compare les jeux demande
se comparer avec le scientifique en chef
non non non non ont dernièrement le
comme de quelqu'un qui avec avait avec
sabrina
ah oui c'est ça c'est ça on parlait du
conflit
jaloux palestiniens petit sabre et nos
mirettes et une journaliste qui a vécu à
jérusalem est et nous expliquer comment
c'était que les conditions de vie t elle
sur la bande de gaza puis une fois tu
comprends surtout deans au thon qui on a
un couvre-feu à 9h30 mais en neuf ans tu
peux encore aller chercher des chip au
dépanneur bien percer ses côtés correct
bombes sur la tête
elle a vu le t2 de ses yeux pitié
pendant qu'elle fait de ses entrevues à
l'entente des tirs de snipers autour de
sa tête le type à 25 ans tu reviens ici
c'est comme ces fous qui nous diront
déchire sa chemise pour justement les
jeudis paquet a eu des effets clairement
n'insisterait certains groupes sociaux
chose que que c'est limitatif à la
liberté mais tu es quand justement je
ramène à qu'on se comparent même à
l'époque présent dans certains endroits
de monde clairement qu'on peut se
consoler qu'est ce qui fait penser qu'on
s'est désolidarisé justement t on en
parlait au début de confinement on se
tenait pas ma naissance et fribourg
continue je pense l'usure du temps
c'est un moment donné oui on est capable
petit je pense que c'est humain est
capable d'être soldat je pense qu'on
l'ait possiblement été encore plus ici
et on est quand même société c'est serré
mais déjà dire nécessairement a pris nos
intérêts personnels qu'ils rentrent en
ligne de compte
après ce bon il ya certaines décisions
je demande qu'ils peuvent être
questionnable disent pas tout le monde
qui est même si c'est aussi d'atterrir
11 par rapport à certaines à certaines
mesures qui après bon le vieux tu peux
vous en avez sûrement parler sur le
podcast et les réseaux sociaux qui leur
est fait aussi nécessité pas seulement
existe un peu partout on a vu un peu le
climat social se dégrade et les tensions
s'accentuent et donc c'est sûr qu'à
partir d'un moment je pense que quand il
ya d'affrontements qui rentrent en ligne
de compte d'ailleurs pas cette espèce de
seine d'arreter mais somme toute quand
même t il ya des sondages qui ont été
faites la grande majorité des québécois
ont respecté les consignes tout
oui il ya eu un effritement au fil du
temps puis oui on ne vit plus de
conflits émerger mais quand même
encore une fois si chaud je pense que
relativement
tf est passée un peu partout dans le
monde on en est quand même là bien sorti
même quand il ya des mauvaises nouvelles
comme dans les chu celle d'exister comme
une espèce d'indignation collective dic
est une hydre à mézin on était tout le
monde ensemble dans cette indignation la
ba oui quand même
justement tu es je pense que tout le
monde s'est dit que c'était inacceptable
qu'il fallait qu'on agisse le
gouvernement quand même été prompts à
poser certains gestes c'est comme avec
une embauche la rapide des préposés aux
bénéficiaires la hausse des salaires
donc de si loin d'être parfait mais ça
me suis pas mal certaines qu'on ait pris
acte justement de certaines leçons que
nous a appris à la pandémie puis j'ose
croire que ça va pas mais la voix des
changements mais mettons mettons qu'on
conseille mais à partir de cette idée là
je suis curieux de savoir parce que dans
dans derrières années en fait on a
clairement ça l'a clairement exacerbée
certaines lacunes qu'on avait tous les
ch et celle des je pense que c'est le
meilleur exemple de ce type
j'aimerais qu'on qu'on fasse un petit
peu le constat en fait le constat global
de plusieurs constats précis qu'on ne
peut faire pendant la pandémie par
rapport à la société québécoise puis
comment on en est arrivé là pis comment
on peut s'en sortir ou son on s'en est
sortis site éphémère donc on essaie de
faire des constats
premièrement critique par rapport à où
est ce qu on était comme avec les lycées
h et celle des pourra éventuellement
plus tard la potée est auteur des
constats positifs de qu'est ce que c'est
possible qu est-ce qu comment on peut en
sortir c'est toi c'est quoi ta frappé
comme étant vraiment les problématiques
qui ont été qui ont ressurgi
durant ce dernier de la dernière année
mais ton mais justement c'est sûr qu'on
peut pas passer à côté du traitement des
personnes âgées c'est ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on en parle au québec j'ai
mon éthique tout jeune qui avait déjà
des reportages sur une tête justement 10
ch et c'est le dit le manque des
services de monde quand j'étais jeune
des histoires du genre un bain par
semaine je voyais jouer passé cela ils
ont le droit à un bain par semaine puis
le dg autant jeter dans l'activité ya
pas si longtemps et je me souviens qu'en
effet les pilleurs était premier
ministre
québec le savent et epic games en
barrettes et ennemi de la santé ou s'ils
savaient fait les marchés
la nourriture j'ai interviewé dans les
ch et celle des donc se dit arvier
périodiquement pu même je pense que
d'envié dans les premières années du
gouvernement charest donc au milieu des
années 2000 c'était déjà un enjeu est
vraiment d'actualité
mais qu'est ce qui arrive souvent c'est
un ange et de l'inactivité là ils vont
avoir des débats à l'assemblée nationale
il va peut-être avoir une deux solutions
qui vont être mises de l'avant l'horizon
on passe à un autre si j'étais jusqu'à
temps qu'il ya eu un autre scandale qui
éclate dans drake mes personnages et
c'est que ce n'est pas vrai que c'est un
peu comme si telle indignation
collective comme les enfin quoique tu es
même les enfants je voudrais la dpj on
en parle beaucoup dans l'actualité ces
derniers temps une commission qui a été
fait mais encore les fait longtemps
qu'on en parle des enfants de la dpj
paul arcand avait fait un documentaire
justement y au moins une dizaine
d'années le peut-être même encore plus
qu avait été vraiment beaucoup vu
pourtant il y avait pas nécessairement
une action qui avait été prise à ce
moment là donc j'ai l'impression que tu
puisses tu feras ton doit revenir
beaucoup et à de nombreuses reprises sur
certains enjeux ou pour traiter certains
sujets pour qu'ils y arrivent vraiment
le des avancées ou peut-être une espèce
de réalisation collective
qu'effectivement il ya quelque chose qui
cloche type y laissèrent chez celles dit
on a beau en plus on peut évidemment
légitimement s'est plaint de la gestion
d'abord du gouvernement mais non d'avoir
peu moins aussi qu' on le sait depuis
des années il n'y a pas tout le monde
qui vous êtes le ch et celle des t il ya
des personnes âgées justement qui sont
les six sont laissés un peu à
le même et c'est aussi ça pose une
réflexion collective sont deux tendances
beaucoup à remettre la responsabilité
dans les mêmes gouvernements légende une
fait indéniable mais une espèce de
responsabilisation collective qu'on a à
voir puis je pense d'entre eux qu'on a
amorcé cette réflexion là encore une
fois peut-être que ça doit prendre du
temps pour que ça change
mais c'est la réflexion sur les milieux
de vie pourrait n'est pas juste d'avoir
la tête lorsqu'on me parle des maisons
pour une ligne de m'en faire des espèces
ch et selby mépris petit plus beaux pas
nécessairement 100% négatif rue je dis
pas qu'il faut améliorer il faut pas
minorer les milieux de vie non est-ce
qu'on peut réfléchir ça à d'autres
alternatives
c'est comment est ce qu'on fait pour
qu'il ya plus de famille qui soit
peut-être prête à avoir des maisons 1
bis générationnel ou à regarder des
personnes en perte lourde autonomie
parce qu'on se cache pas cependant les
ch et celle des styles que mais d'avoir
plus d'un an par exemple 10 ya un décès
dans les communautés cinq ans a été créé
le laisser le fil l'objectif est d'avoir
beaucoup de ressources pour que ça
devienne vraiment rester rvices de santé
implantées dans les communes aux tic
puissent aller à domicile c'est déjà une
comédie manque énormément de ressources
mais pourtant ça coûterait beaucoup
moins cher d'investir dans les
stellistes et qui est de construire tout
le temps des nouvelles infrastructures
de maison des amis et que j'étais europe
les personnes en danger j'aimerais mieux
être dans un milieu familial
il ya plein de gens qui aimeraient être
capable de garder leurs parents à la
maison
donc tu es je pense qu'il faut aussi
réfléchir en dehors du camp tu peux
juste de thermal c'est juste le ch de
celles définies peut-être de trouver des
solutions plus innovantes expérience et
d'esquisser des menus à travailler des
soins de nice elle n'a pas réellement
comme une solution ou comme une avenue
évidente le teint clair que la personne
notre jugerait la personne qui a vécu
dans sa maison familiale il ya un
relâchement entier a vu rester le plus
longtemps possible aussi longtemps
qu'ils avouent être capable de le faire
puis je croyais sottement capable
d'entendre ces statistiques le ticket en
ce moment mettons-les l'argent destiné
aux soins pour les années si 80% pour
d'une institution comme et sasha 7 dépit
20% pour le soin à son domicile pillé
des pays où est-ce que c'est l'inversé
80 pour les soins à domicile puis 20%
pis je ça ça doit être un meilleur
système
genre je fonderai que j'en suis comme
convaincu pour tout le monde note et je
suis certaine aussi et on pose la
question à des personnes c'est angers
mais qui sont pas nécessairement rendu
lundi en perte d'autonomie avancée pied
clairement c'est ce qu'ils répondent en
majorité le tout le monde aimerait mieux
rester chez soi je vais aller dans un
spv d'institutions quand même bien qu'on
fait des beaux jardins ainsi que ce type
sera fixé dans belfort ont fait des
activités humaines
quand la personne a choisi de rester
chez eux dans cette affaire où avec sa
famille ce qui est intéressant c'est
quand on vieillit aussi ce qui va nous
permettre de rester en forme qui est
allumé puis c'est d'abord des contacts
sociaux sylvie puis d'être dans sa
famille de se sentir utile au site est
de pouvoir un des deux projets sec dans
sa chambre toute la journée comme pas
trop avant d'activités à faire c'est
saâdane à garder le plus longtemps
possible ses capacités cognitives france
entend rester comme le souhaite tout le
monde je pensais ne vieillit reste
encore cher que le leader dans l'attenté
d'être allumé de pouvoir intégrer l
ensemble de ses facultés mentales
si on avait reçus c'est comme un petit
boulot tu es ma été saganash sur le
podcast expliqué que dans les
communautés autochtones cccc la norme le
fait d'avoir d'aider les foyers
bigénérationnelle le tipi ça fait aussi
que si la méthode le les parents
travaillent on met les enfants à 100 de
la petite enfance par exemple ou en
garderie métier quant aux silos
génération et la belle ça peut
participer aussi à élever les enfants
les parents pour le travail et les
grands parents prennent le relais de on
dirait que ça la saq montrer ça crée un
système qui qui s'autosuffise vraiment
plus en fait ouais vraiment petit moi
j'ai eu cette chance-là fait gmt avec ma
grand mère pendant 13 ans ouais quand
acheter aux primaires
la mère de ma mère est venue à petit à
la maison on devait déménager c'était
pas clair mais finalement autres cons ça
peut ça peut fonctionner puis on lui a
juste comme ça on avait une chambre
d'amis dont le seul avec un petit talon
donc elle comme on a aménagé l'espace
est pour elle donc ma grand mère quand
les déménager chez nous elle avait 80
ans est décédée aujourd'hui décédé à
langer 93 donc j'ai vécu au moins une
dizaine d'années avec elle était
justement tellement aidée aussi
mes parents des camps et moi j'ai deux
frères plus jeunes aussi notre secteur
qui est encore plus s'occuper de zulte
et moi mon le staff industrie mère du
jeune est capable quand même des motifs
de ma main mais dont on venait nous
devenir la maison le midi étaient à nous
préparer à nous faisait manger tard et
préparer le déjeuner le matin était
juste celles primées par un aparté
spartoo travail et partant à 5 6 heures
du matin non ici on n'avait pas eu ma
grand-mère t on arrêter comme au service
de garde et dès l'ouverture puis on
serait quand je suis arrivé sa garde à
la ferme tout et comme beaucoup
d'enfants elles le font mais je dis moi
je me sens hyper privilégié d'avoir eu
l'occasion de vivre j'aimerais que ma
grand-mère qui qui pouvait prendre soin
nous qui a fait en sorte qu'on apportait
plus de temps c'est à la maison toute
attente - au service de garde quand
c'est possible qui pourrait elle aussi
dit je suis certaine elle a eu toute sa
tête jusqu'à la fin si sera payé quand
même des éléments la vieillesse tu n'es
pas remarqué mais j'écris c'est vraiment
formidable partie elle je le voyais dans
les yachts et à la vie des étincelles tu
étais contente juste de pouvoir aider le
juste de lui demander et mamie petit
frère est telle chose était donc bien
contente et elle aurait tout fait pour
nous puis je pense que c'est vraiment ce
qui là qu'il a gardé en vie étaient
parler un mot déni elle avait eu un
accident puis elle a dû aller dans un
centre de réhabilitation pendant près de
trois mois puisqu'elle avait tellement
perdu des fous comme intervilles la
suite suffit d'une petite à fort le
puits
une affaire qui vient mettons nuire à ta
mobilité justement peut-être et de
l'action sociale puis puisque c'est sa
part exponentiellement rapidement oui
oui d'ailleurs une des causes de
mortalité les plus élevés c'est une
fracture de la hanche pour tous n'est
pas quelque chose des mortels mais parce
que j'avais exactement va être
immobilisé pendant un certain temps où
va justement ce temps des
réhabilitations
mais ça veut diminuer tellement ses
capacités cognitives qui au final va
être plus sensibles aux maladies du cip
ce c'est comme un engrenage qui va faire
en sorte que pas rater le vent autre
chose que la personne va finir par des
cdd
on parlait avec jonathan brouillette qui
est un spécialiste sur la mémoire puis
l'alzheimer s'est lui dit inquiet pour
les choses à faire c'est de garder mes
problèmes et saines habitudes de vie
c'est la base mais pour retarder les
hammers est resté actif puis les
interactions sociales celles de zafour
puis la mort quand ça arrive c'est là
que tu le manges le vietnam à grand var
vient juste de rentrer dans un siège
celle des arts connais plus son
entourage le tipi
c'est à ce moment là que ça devient
vraiment difficile pour la famille de
rester lui c'est ça qui en tirent la
personne qui ne reconnaît plus effectué
c'est est ce qu'il ya des effets selon
toi de la pandémie dans les têtes un
grand mère c'est sûr que je les pose une
fois de la pandémie le thé fait que
c'est sûr que ça le poète je la voyais
pas souvent quand même là mais
métier le journal des panels pas de thé
fixer sur salat accéléré c'est ça notre
combat plus isolé j'ai hâte de voir les
listes définitives d'avoir eu sans les
changer le système qui veut comme que
j'ai l'impression l'équipe va voir ça
c'est assez grande et prouver les
quantités pas d'interaction sociale ton
cerveau va mêmes stats rush et c'est
comme un muscle au travail et c'est le
même principe donc je pense qu'il va
peut-être avoir une étude de contribuer
les mineurs de checker les prochaines
années de ces mêmes pour les jeunes
aussi le pied on en parle beaucoup les
jeunes est ce que les interactions
sociales ça vote soit quelque chose qui
m'ont pouvoir rattraper rapidement
peut-être que oui peut-être que non
tissés tout dit c'est intéressant de
garder les effets à long terme
moi je trouve ça fou quand je pense
qu'il ya des jeunes qui vont finir leur
sujet sans y avoir été auprès
l'expérience pas réduite mais cours en
ligne
j'ai porté le c comme ce truc tellement
que les cégeps une période déterminante
d'autres comme moi ça a été pour moi
c'est souvent ça fait aujourd'hui le
cégep ce soit ce soit c'est déterminant
soutenu par l'ong mag peut-être d'avoir
une écoute en ligne de certaines paires
mais quand même c'est pas ma voix mais
tente aménagée testage lettre comme tu
dois arrêter dans ta chambre dans ton
seul coup comme par des quotas trop voir
et qui comptait imagine quelqu'un qui a
pas encore je n'ai pas encore trouvé
qu'ils aiment pas encore trouvé sa
passion dans la vie comme c'est souvent
le cas mais je me dis pas en avant de
s'amuser
imagine joystick en main le court philo
aux cégeps tout le temps qu est ce que
le monde arrive loeb style qu'aucune
crise des deux c'est un peu ça joue le
rôle de team et imaginent qu'on sort de
son maire 5 t sur sciences nat ou
sciences humaines clôture en plein cours
en ligne de philo aucune idée
c'est qu elle ait aucune des jardins
coda ça sent les côtés y aura discussion
c'est je suis l'apologie de sa graphie
lequel il a fait quoi elle est faite les
sachets cd ceci c'est évident après ça
on a quand même rencontré des problèmes
de logistique quand être quand on s'est
rendu compte qu'on avait un peu besoin
de l'import pour nous nous sortir du
pétrin et mettons avec les masques ou
avec les vaccins et en ce moment qu'on
voit puis le fait qu'on n'avait pas
l'autonomie complète de ces choses là ça
faisait quand même nuit oui ça c'est ça
dans le fond tout comment tu le bus
s'est tue parce que c'est eu quelque
chose tu mets ton on en a entendu parler
le pharma québec les potences y était
une idée lancée comme ça je pense qu'ils
s'étaient québec soldats thaïlandais
puis c'est ça mais moi mettons cette
idée là je n'avais jamais entendu parler
de femme à québec avant avant l'aube ce
ça fait longtemps pied je trouve qu'il
s'est illustré exactement ce qu'ils
disent depuis des années où j'ai
toujours été d'accord avec cette idée le
des filets tarmac est ma seule idée mais
tu sais quoi puis commence à répu
semaine et se manifester
comment ça ce serait représentée dans la
crise que nos vécus
mais l'idée c'est d'avoir les capacités
de production chez nous d'éléments
névralgiques comme telle limite à main
là on parle des vaccins plus
spécifiquement c'est pas normal de
devoir dépendre de l'étranger c'est de
toutes ces ressources ou de peu de
postes garder un potentiel chez nous par
cas précis mais on devient tél on se
rend tellement vite
rabelais dépendant aux autres peux t on
touche du bois ça c'est quand même bien
passé jusqu'à maintenant on en est
simple tout bien sorti mais c'est
imaginer une autre tombe ils n'ont ni
encore plus meurtrière à des kits gelé
toutes les strates de la population qui
touche les enfants
si on se fie aux sciences est probable
en exemple conscience et des relations
entre la santé et l'environnement est
clair qu'un réchauffement est planétaire
c'est sûr qu'on est pas sorti du bois
qu'est ce que ça va donner mais
effectivement il ya des prévisions qui
sont plutôt sombres et à ce chapitre là
mais donc si on n'a pas cette capacité
des producteurs de lait il ya vraiment
une espèce de panique qui s'empare la
somme toute dans le chapitre des
pandémies ça a été très grave je mettais
à quelque chose que tu prennes qui
quittent arrache les jambes mais tu sais
c'est aussi certaines maladies qui ne
serait ce que le choléra l'ebola qui a
eu aussi en afrique tu sais pas mal
puisque la ville
donc si on a peut-être apporter leur
production chez nous donc on y est
extrêmement limitée on dépend de nos
relations avec les autres puis
évidemment on voit les réflexes de tous
les pays du monde c'est de desservir
leur peuple à son premier succès
pourtant comme les actions imagine un
dirigeant politique
vous nous donnez éviction québec à place
de deux ex de l'arizona en public
c'est juste normal quand donc d'où
l'importance qu'il a même chose avec des
masses côté dit c'est ce qu'on est
tellement délocaliser nos entreprises
manufacturières cette dernière des
signes et je veux dire parce que c'est
moins cher de produire ailleurs mais
tout en réalisant peu l'effet stratégie
que ça peut avoir quand il ya des
moments extrêmement importants ou des
moments décisifs où on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir une production locale
heureusement encore lui qui a quand même
des gens qui se sont retournés sur une
scène tendue des entreprises thion qui
ont levé la main pour dire non
en faire du désinfectant nous avons
faire des marches non vent faire des des
équipements de sécurité pour le
personnel de la santé mettez imagine
qu'on avait pu inscrire morissette cette
culture-là des comme d'entre elles se
développer on aurait pu être vraiment
dans le trouble ont été les cinq
charmantes et on était au top il ya
plein de monde qui ont été mardi
on a sans doute perdu beaucoup de vies
pour cette raison les produits beauté
dans le déni on commence pas grave
peut-on besoin de mars mais qui
finalement s'est rendu compte que c'est
parce qu'ils voulaient composeront
alerter la population parce qu'on en
avait pas de masque ouais ouais mais on
dit que c'est ça aussi qu'on s'est rendu
compte avec la pandémie c'est comme les
limites ou les limites de la
mondialisation dans le format noté
people comme on s'est rendu compte à
quel point je demande une telle
interdépendantes
c'est comme ces maisons ne reçurent une
couple de semaines jean martin forte il
est agriculteur ticket lui qui prend
vraiment l'agriculture de proximité
typique justement qui être le plus petit
qu'un village thomas puisse être
autosuffisants l'atypique chacun en plus
il ya plus de gens qui s'intéressent à
la production le calcio pour qu'on
puisse subvenir à nos propres besoins le
plus possible puis aussi sur vos phares
qui vont avoir un impact positif sur
l'environnement
mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont en
train de se rendre compte finalement en
2021 que ça fait des décennies je dois
me concernant dans une traque puis
finalement cette tracklist peut-être pas
la destruction
c'est la meilleure solution peut-être
pour produire au plus bas coût possible
pour alimenter aussi le capitalisme
petit mais manifestement ça a ses
limites comme s'ils y étaient oui bon il
peut y avoir des raisons pour laquelle
une entreprise de râler produira à
l'étranger ils s'entendaient des raisons
de maximisation du profit est long on
parle des effets stratégie que ça peut
avoir sur les états et on peut aussi
parler
et j'espère aussi que ça a ouvert la
discussion sur le fait de délocaliser
c'est aussi d'aller et ses abords du
chip leader international dans des
conditions de travail qui sont
absolument
épouvantable qui sont pas nécessairement
est régulée été au prix au prix de quad
cette anticipation produisait chez nous
c'est sûr qu'il y aurait peut-être moins
de profits que ça coûte cher ça coûte
très cher aux consommateurs
mais en contrepartie va peut-être que
justement on a créé des produits de
meilleure qualité on a rien d
infrastructures névralgique on en avait
besoin puis nécessairement aussi on
contrôle à ce moment là les conditions
de les conditions de travail en
attendant ce danger qui se parlent en
jeu parce que en même temps que ça donne
quand même des emplois on à l'extérieur
mais à quel prix ces emplois l'été
confié à quel point il avait été élevé
mais gros scandale ceci juste la pointe
de l'iceberg et bernard david
d'entreprise oui les gens viennent de
dieu mais c'est qu'ils risquaient leur
vie à tous les jours pour aller
travailler tellement que les conditions
étaient plus mentalement dans les usines
ou et j'étais totalement absurde
là-dedans nautique est ici justement ça
fait deux derniers siècles ce moment
qu'on s'est battus pour de meilleures
conditions que le syndicalisme est
arrivé s'est piqué et on demande un
meilleur salaire minimum secundo on se
bat mais qu'accéder truc con côté miss
il s'était fait la bosse c'est comme si
c'est correct c'est comme si quand on le
voit pas les règlements par kilomètre
plus loin que c'est le chef qui
exactement je coachais plus gros malin
celui qui a le plus c'est ton voisin
monde que s'il ya cinq chinois reste
apprécié que c'est une catastrophe
justement qui arrive près de chez toi
sap touche mais à l'autre bout du monde
tant que tu vois peu on abuse la
politique québécois mais on peut habiter
[Musique]
autant québécois mais c'est vrai aussi
pour être quelqu'un qui va vivre en inde
au bangladesh qui venait ça m'a touchée
par ces jeux d'hiver
sinon après seul lorsqu'on réalise
puis je pense plus que jamais c'est le
manque d'accessibilité aux ressources
d'aed en santé mentale chez que
moi personnellement j'ai commencé à
consulter pendant la pandémie
ça a été content qu'il trouvait
quelqu'un put aller au privé genre juste
au bon moment avant que tout le monde ya
eu non pas vraiment homogène au mauvais
moment et puis tu es moi je suis
privilégié d'avoir les moyens de payer
psychologue un bon montant pour m'aider
c'est sûr que c'est vraiment pas le cas
de tout le monde
puis je t'envoie lines s'ils sont prêts
à payer ils en trouvent pas ouais c'est
sûr aussi docile et puis comment est-ce
que c'était un enjeu sur lequel on avait
attiré l'attention avant puis qu'est ce
qui est une façon de régler ce crs aussi
si je pense que la lumière a été
beaucoup aimé jacquet subi tant mieux
parce que ça fait longtemps le quai des
problèmes d'accessibilité aux services
en santé mentale et la virtu appris
général du québec avait d'ailleurs fait
un rapport à ce sujet lors de sorties en
ondes cet automne comme quoi on a fait
le québec et même pas vraiment de
données sur l'accès aux soins et
services de santé mentale donc oui un
problème qu'il ya tellement eu de
changement qui sont devenus vulnérables
qui ont hué qui ont eu besoin de six au
même moment que je pense qu'elles ont
été sensibilisés encore une fois assez à
ce sujet le gouvernement comme hadji
mais s'ils parlent autrement ce parce
que c'est difficile de rattraper des
bises mais ce succès il faut faire
attention t on peut évidemment et
critique que je ne peux qui ont pris les
meilleures décisions dans le meilleur
labs étant loin de là mais on doute
affirme vincent qui a un indice sur
l'investissement dans quelque chose on
peut pas attendre que ça change du jour
au lendemain parce que les graves
problèmes eux tentent autant les sages
ce samedi l'on parle et sentimentale
c'est là on est tellement de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre dans plein de domaines et
notamment les domaines liés à la santé
parce que on ne collectivement un peu
fermé les yeux sur le fait qu il y avait
des mauvaises conditions de travail dans
le secteur la santé et on a parlé de
coucher avec proposer des infirmières
ces dernières années mettez nosocomiales
on leur demande du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire il rentre le matin savent
pas compter 6 heures ils ont des enfants
ils leur demandent de faire un double un
double cheese quand tu y arrives au
travail travailler c'est un visa manger
dame infirmières travaillent ce teaser
de ses commandos à bord étaient saufs le
mandat ni le stress la pression petits
petons qu'infirmière tpiy bien payé mais
quand même somme toute moyen quand même
faut que ce soit une passion un
emprisonnement quand même est exactement
une vocation pis si c'est un peu comme
ça dans beaucoup métier film n'a rien
maintenant comme celles primées comment
le communautaire c'est aussi je trouve
que ça a été un mois puis mis en lumière
cette année dit on était vraiment
première ligne les organismes avec la
population notre comme député je n'ai
vraiment constaté t on leur a demandé de
rester ouverts rester anonyme de
contenir leurs services de bonifier leur
théorie mais je t'avais des gens les
traits d'un communautaire souvent il ya
un diplôme universitaire qui sont payés
comme kenzo loves take à 1 16 dollar
parce que lors du bain c'est une
vocation d'être un homme comme l'auteur
atomique chaque fois qu'il y mettait
plus féminin en satin comme
l'enseignement même chose deux options
je pense qu'on ait vu de très près
certaines problématiques l'histoire de
sempé et le communautaire destine
votation donc d andré qu'on prend pour
acquis que c'est des salaires qui sont
moins houleux les éducatrices la petite
enfance il ya comme un gros mouvement
les qui s'appelle ma place au travail
donc les jeunes mamans qui sont pas
capables de retourner travailler parquet
elles sont pas capables de trouver une
carte pour leurs enfants
pourquoi mais ce parc est éducatrice en
service de garde donc d une grande
majorité de femmes qui ont pourtant des
diplômes était en fait une technique de
trois ans mais pour pouvoir travailler
dans un cbr elles sont payés parfois dos
13 de leur 14 2 lors de leur offrant
soin d'enfants dont on augmente
constamment les ratios donc on donne de
plus en plus d'enfants à s'équiper à une
éducatrice du film en principe dans
l'est dans les hôpitaux dans les chsld
et on donne de plus en plus de patients
on ose employer donc dans le tessin est
responsable et une infirmière un nombre
x de partir lui demande d'en prendre
plus d'en prendre plus est travailleur
styger est patent pays et c'est comme
une espèce de cercle vicieux qui fait en
sorte qu'ils manient le monde vont
quitter yvon larcher qui il n'y a pas
tant de monde qui vont suivre en arrière
pour la comédie mêlant ce moment dans
les tpe dans les garderies on voit les
filles d'à peu près 15 ans justement où
yavin et qui a été fait pour améliorer
la station ça fait au moins cinq ans
qu'on voit une baisse drastique des
inscriptions dans les cégeps dans les
techniques la petite enfance
on ne peut pas agi parce que la crise
est un peu maintenant justement c'est
montrer que je pars en politique tu es
une espèce de vision court termiste
on est là on règle les problèmes qui en
ce moment de voir dans cinq ans le
devoir que les young boys un soupçon
dans les cégeps pour quelque chose tu
veux nous apparaît pendant cinq six ans
au fond rôle règlent leurs comptes
rendus la belle elle est fait c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya un espèce d'explosion
c'est incroyable on est rendu que du
parrain jean voile c'est vie de leur
bébé dans un journal pour espérer
espérer trouver quelqu'un qui va vouloir
aller garder l'enfant à la maison w
cherche des yeux regardiez blaye ya
vraiment plein groupe la cour sa photo
la preuve qu'ils n'ont pas sur une
quarantaine qui y va il ya même un
départ effectivement qui ont fait des
annonces dans les journaux quand même
des qualités des compétences de leurs
enfants pour
quelqu'un qui vienne l'éducation le
trait c'est tellement peur sans doute la
chose la plus importante dans une
société
la leaf là surtout qui je compte et ça
c'est quelque chose de manquer une
enseignante au primaire que ce soit pas
plus valorisé que ce soit pas plus mieux
payé ses employés cpe même chose ça me
dépasse je comprends pas
justement dans toute utilité les limites
si typiquement finissent par hasard
quand tu es maintenant cas c'est vrai au
razer pc c'est typique accueillez des
métiers typiquement guillemets masculin
c'est qui qui demandent pas plus
d'années d'études qui demande des moyens
des pays outil qui on a besoin ce genre
mais aussi des proportions au niveau des
serveurs qui est qui et quand même
quelques bons sens littéralement fait
qu'elles doublent en fait aux castrais
en commençant construction par dp quoi
200 organisateurs entendent à la fois
une femme qui étudie parce que j'étais
encore une femme parce qu'on s'entend
que celle à l'image des jeunes et des
trois ans un dec pour finalement et
éducatrices en cpe cinquième des enfants
laissés là je viens défendre c'est sûr
c'est important aussi la construction
vox à céline crocro très jeunes enfants
mettons que c'est un atout important
également que se lève et on fait un bond
à égal
super mais là comme ça et puis pourquoi
qu'ont accepté un tel qu'ils s'équipent
de l'avenir de nos enfants soient payés
installe ensuite qu'est ce que c'est
pourquoi par constatant que sa seule ce
matin que les femmes cinquième des
enfants mangent entre les deux pays se
trouve quasiment que c'est chaud c'est
tellement insultant je trouve que c'est
le message qu'on envoie un petit salaire
d'appoint le tutoie ça devrait être tout
naturel que tu t'occupes d'enfants est
bien quelqu'un qui serait une mauvaise
foi puis qui dirait comme contre
argument béton ben vas-y en construction
qu'est-ce que tu répondre est attendu à
la bonne méthode
dans cet actif c'est ce qui a fait ce qu
est la france ne me connaît très mal et
encore street on va aller ailleurs faire
autre chose moi je suis pour rien je te
manque une base d'exceptions dans
d'anciens été autant je sais pas
exactement des statistiques en soins
infirmiers maintenant qu'on reprend les
techniques alpins à la petite enfance
parce que le gie des rencontres
récemment la type iut mans les
statistiques sont claires et nettes ça
fait longtemps qu'on peut l'avoir vu
venir le ya même certaines certains
cégeps qui ont pratiquement fermé leur
programme mais cette année notamment qui
avait pas assez d'inscriptions mais elle
est estimée ton en ce moment fait que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que lhasa son
geste a gravé dans les prochaines années
puis à ces fameux aileron justin à autre
chose mais jésus peut exactement vers où
elles vont se rediriger m'a clairement
que tu as dix ans j'allais faire trois
ans de ces gènes pour aller m'occuper
d'enfants d'invention vraiment d'ici peu
comme si tu allais bien compris dans ces
pays est là justement dans le technicien
moins en moins de femmes témoignent
d'éducatrice de jeunes enfants jusqu'à
12 ans tandis qu'à triste qu'on a
augmenté grâce au parc un manet et on
peut vraiment j'ai le choix entre
guillemets parce que tu veux maintenir
les services à clé les directrices de
cpm antomarchi ballon va augmenter on va
augmenter les restos ici bon il ya un
gouvernement qu'il permet également fait
récemment il ya eu un décrite justement
permis d'augmenter les ratios des
ministres vers un peu avec raison mais
qu'est ce que c'est quoi l'alternative
de fermer des groupes si tu peux envoyer
un fax de six ans même pas du sud
exacerbées temps c'est pas normal qu'on
en sort grandie leurs facs les scellés
qu'il faut voir à long terme qu'il faut
réaliser qui est ce qu'elle est les
effets de ce fonds se passe en fait
encore pendant longtemps l'on va pas
régler le problème en peu avant des
places tout comme six maires mais ça
peut régler demain matin puis en
augmentant seulement les ratios puis en
faisant en sorte que y en a encore plus
sur les épaules le taxant de sédition
passait rien de moins en moins sa valeur
tenter d'aller parce qu'on parlait
plutôt des services elle dit qu'ils
étaient de temps en temps ça revienne à
le piloter dans les médias puis
l'opinion publique un petit une grande
qui pilot opt qui va avoir une action
posée ou sur ce jeu l'impression pis
j'imagine que tu dis ce que tu vas être
d'accord avec moi qui la politique c'est
des fois il ya des choses qui ont su
qu'un problème étant que pau
tant que l'opinion publique ne met pas
la pression pizza cats au pied du mur on
s'occupe des trucs justement le qui fait
les manchettes
parce qu'il ya un côté électoraliste et
ça c'est quand même des programmes par
un outil vraiment toujours à réaction à
l'actualité et à l'opinion plutôt
qu'elle juste parce qu'il ya problème
n'est en rien le problème le soutenons à
part ça personne n'en parle mais c'est
aussi important on va s'en occuper aussi
tu sais comment ça arrive pas juste non
pied effectivement c'est aussi je pense
que comme une accélération du phénomène
le plus
je pensais depuis un début des années 90
quoi que les médias continuent de ces
réseaux télé tnt en arménie et qui
tourne
puis ça a été comme un premier facteur
peut qu'amener je pense encore plus télé
les gens politiques à réagir constamment
ce qu'il a fait dans l'activité là avec
les réseaux sociaux ça a été accentuée
encore davantage depuis une liste de 12
ans maintenant je sais c'est que c'est
mon plus grand constat lé puis
maintenant de ma position de députés
indépendantistes et je revois ta part
des partis d pad espace pour comprendre
qu'elle peut réfléchir moi j'en suis là
parce que j'ai un indépendant qui je
peux tenus de réagir à tout ce qui se
passe dans l'immédiat si j'ai pas tout
le temps un métro justement devant moi
pour comme donner ma position sur xg
avec nouvelle saveur du jour
si on veut mais les partisans comme sont
comme un peu contraint à se distinguer
en fait qui se nourrit un peu des deux
côtés mais les partis veulent à présent
dans l'opinion publique donc veulent à
présent dans les médias les médias ont
de moins en moins de ressources moins en
moins de journalistes souci pour couvrir
les différents sujets donc souvent ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'un journaliste
de faire un reportage sur extreme y
sujet puis là mais pour nourrir par la
suite son reportage où il va aller
chercher des réactions de la part de
tout le monde qui va essayer de faire
vivre son sujet pendant un certain temps
par cas mais tant que c'est lui qui a eu
l'exclusivité balle ça va être comme
payants pour son média qui fasse donc le
lendemain mais il va aller capter les
réactions encore t'es comme les
réactions sur les réactions
il ya eu des débats houleux à
l'assemblée nationale par exemple sur le
sujet le parachute en or un autre
article sur le sujet nantis on récupère
constamment puis donc si comme une
espèce de file de réaction de très peu
de pro activité est très peu de
dirigeants de kiel est un enjeu qui peut
dans les médias pour intervenir dessus
puis team pour l'avoir vu la game à
l'intérieur c'est qu'on veut faire c'est
très difficile parce que le tennis comme
gaston maintenant qu'ils vont dire -
mais l'essai on n'intervient pas sur ce
sujet là c'est seul sujet du jour c'est
selon les médias vont parler ici c'est
que les émissions de fin de journée il
ya d une salle avec des commentateurs
propos je peux en a mis les millions
d'hommes et ont deux principales mais on
veut avoir un teint équipe
si on veut que les commentateurs parlent
de nous estimons avoir
mettons les légendes et communication
dans les parties les staffs d'avancé
quel sujet le vent a peut-être été parce
qu'ils sont en contact avec des
recherchistes mettons de s'immiscer en
l'air ils vont essayer de positionner
les réactions du parti en fonction de ce
qui va être traité dans l'immédiat
effectif jeudi que cette espèce de
grosse game au final c'est très prenant
qui a planté les ressources quand même
au québec la politique mais la game est
juste plus grosse ailleurs même s'ils
ont plus de ressources donc cette usine
par exemple même année il était pas il
est encarté dans cet engrenage le temps
de penser à prochaine affaire de penser
à des dix 10 pieds en avant d'être un
sim et on dit mais tintin degrés de
différence le temps qu'il faut que ça en
vaut un petit peu un petit peu à côté le
team et se traite dans dix ans placé le
traité au début alors que c'est tout
petit et l'enjeu mettant justement
augmenté mettons le salaire de deux
pièces de leur mettons d'aider des
éducatrices et on ne sait pas si une
solution qui changerait quoi que ce soit
la météo qu'on donne comme exemple un
petit dossier le disculpant au début le
t20 il ya une balise d'inscription et
quelque chose là on reste sur du bon
hockey on vient de me protéger mais
comment tu fais que mathis fait pour
modifier ça c'est quoi la solution pour
que
la politique devient trop active en fait
bonnes questions vraiment parti
communiste est présente à relier avec
avec les médias moi je pense que ça
serait plus facile d'agir sur les médias
d'abord pour après avoir une influence
sur la politique que les médias se
mettent à traiter dangereux qui sont
pauvres et d'appuyer davantage et me dit
on sait que les médicaments vivent une
grave crise depuis plusieurs années
justement les services de presse sont de
plus en plus réduites et il ya eu
tellement de cooper deux dernières
années de moins en moins de journalistes
pour couvrir les évènements on la remet
de plus en plus sur les épaules puis on
l'étendait de plus en plus dans la
nouvelle phase il aussi loin un pied
monstre c'était un peu le
sensationnalisme à fossettes et c'est la
guerre des clics sont les rivaux c'est
comme ça maintenant qu'il faut qu'ils
font de l'argent plus nécessairement t
comme un peu panier parce que peut avoir
du bon journalisme de qualité il faut
que tu ailles l'argent comment que ça
c'est l'argent et dans l'immédiat par la
publicité
les gens investissent moyens publicité
partie investie sur les réseaux sociaux
la couleur qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour avoir plus des financements
ah ça c'est la sela 6 et le circuit cela
mais ces furies la lumière dessus à quel
point l'immédiat finalement pour le
meilleur et pour le pays ils font de la
politique active le dolfijn les médias
ont un rôle pour le meilleur et pour le
pire
non mais parce que j'imagine que je
convaincu qui était une fois le métro
journée les enfants montent un dossier
sur un enjeu qui passait dans le bac
passé dans l'ombre qui qu'il l'amène
piqué le fis qui l'a amené sa folle de
poussif l'outil ouais tout arrive
mais j'arrive encore à convaincre la
main effectivement d y en ait qui vont
avoir qu'ils vont pouvoir faire des
reportages de fonte et je veux y en a un
petit peu plus et un centre et que comme
une espèce de prise de conscience dans
certains médias qui est aussi un peu que
les gens recherchent activement mais en
même temps ça demeure une situation qui
est quand même très précaire dans la
foire des lits des médias pied csq m si
justement on peut changer un peu la
dynamique puis après c'est difficile
parce que comme je dis à la vitesse où
sicre et l'intensité
et ça fait 1 amène des choses croit un
truc ce serait une première piste de
réflexion pour changer cela donne en
lien avec la politique mais je suggère
été suggéré quoi qu'on qu'on finance
plus l'information le journalisme
objectif l'effet du j'imagine que ça
passerait parle beaucoup le témoin
possible départ dans des publicités plus
exactement faire en sorte que les mines
soient de moins en moins dépendant de la
publicité car d'autres sources de
financement de cette façon là justement
c'est très peu il répète comme un
incitatif au sensationnalisme dans la
gare des clés qui répond il pourrait y
avoir davantage de ressources dans les
médias non seulement les médias
nationaux mais ces dernières années un
peu la crise lance des médias c'est
l'apparition des journaux locaux et des
journaux régionaux qui ont ainsi moins
en moins de ressources qui deviennent
carrément des catalogues publicitaires
et les tic comme de trois articles de
bain qu'ils restent massés la pub à
petit les articles des jeux d'hier mais
quand les gens un journaliste qui doit
couvrir toute l'actualité d'une ville ou
de plusieurs partis si juste impossible
qu'il fasse c'est appréciable
l'information va être pauvre qui l'est
tout la démocratie qui vont souffrir
mais après si ça peut nous amener vers
un autre enjeu le problème c'est que
justement des finances et des médias à
quelqu'un qui ose qui a pas confiance en
les médias qui s'abreuve de medio
alternative puis de faire le terreau
natif ça le fera encore plus c'est
d'avoir d'avoir financé des médias
lequel l'appo confiance qui reconnaît
pas la légitimité mais dont on le voit
de plus en plus ou si c'était un
phénomène important
en même temps j'ai fait oui en a
toujours qui m'ont critiqué les
décisions si on en ce moment là qui
critiquent les financements de radio
canada y en a depuis depuis longtemps
avec
avec mais pas toujours des mécontents
je pense que quand même d'avoir le souci
disent les médias peuvent avoir si le
souci de autant comme les gens politique
de comme reconstruire une certaine
confiance perdue avec une frange de la
population
tj tout restait possible de le faire si
elle se soucie là ne pas créer juste
avant son départ un fossé encore plus
grande était d'avoir des stratégies pour
rétablir les pentes et comment est-ce
qu'on peut aller chercher société dans
un métier par exemple cette frange de la
population l'équipe très riche pas
croire à nous qui ne croient plus qu'il
croit plus en nous
comment est-ce qu'on veut réussir à
créer des films on a rajouté je dois y
ait des familles qui parle pull duty jeu
des yeux des séparations fake images ici
c'est même pas quelqu'un pour qui
traînent affecté me dire que c'est juste
un pape il tient un journal ou un site
web outils comment tu fais pour
reconstruire si pour lui je pense que ça
va être la question des prochaines
années j'ai l'impression parce que
tellement je pense que je pense a jamais
été aussi divisés depuis je pense que ça
va être de voir qu'est ce qui se passe
après manger j'ai hâte de voir les
prochains est ce qu est ce qu on va
divinement toujours toutes les questions
partir de maintenant têtu rendu ce
novice du rand seul québec sur indices
utiles les réseaux sociaux vraiment où
ben excuse c'était juste sur cet enjeu
là qui est anecdotique qui est gros mais
qui est anecdotique c'est ça lesquels
celui la pandémie celui de la gestion
celui de titres des médias traditionnels
qu'on croit pu celui des masses tout
c'est tout ce panda 2 com est ce que
c'est juste sur lens en ce moment parce
que c'est une période qui est le même
combien se diviser où est-ce que savoir
où est-ce qu'ils sont vastes la
prochaine étape c'est à dire quelque
chose d'autre qui va continuer comme ça
moi aussi je me pose beaucoup ces
questions là ça va ça tellement été
exacerbée par notamment finalement avec
lesquels on est est un habitué des
contrairement au sud de la frontière par
exemple que les états unis la
polarisation sociale on tente qu'ils
étaient prêts très présent qui s'est
accentué aussi par les réseaux sociaux
aussi chez nous monsieur
mais quand même plutôt consensuelle en
général c'est juste comme ça a été un
phénomène auquel on s'attendait pas
nécessairement ça se passe aussi dans le
contexte en plus comme tout entremêlé
déjà je vois que ça a l'air un peu moins
pénible sur les réseaux trick je pense
depuis de suie qui annoncent ils
plantent de confinement je pense que
tout le monde attendait au nom
on dirait que finalement ils voulaient
pas nous garder les finir qu'en mars
contre un non-système et au gisti
justement depuis certaines franges
complète ici ce qui était proche on peut
croire qu' on conseille d'enlever tout a
été fait à quelle sauce d'information
on a l'impression que d'importer
certains d'affaires chez nous donc je
note que jean kinck on le sait
nourrissez style encourager c'est un
disque élu nouveau président c'est pour
ça que c'est sûr que ça calme plus le
tamiflu chez nous maintenant à rallier
va après john dahl clim aujourd hui
ramener tout le temps sur l'idée que
nous l'avons confiance en studio puis
c'est fatras nous affecter
le lendemain c'est la puissance des
médias le lendemain des élections
américaines
on parlait plus d'autres c'est comme les
mêmes qu'en lui il se battait pour
remettre en question les élections les
médians juste arrêté on je suis tourné
la page avec un mag et londres ont lancé
tout au long comme bloquer plus appuyé
plus dans notre shop existe comme plus
d'un est un peu limité comme criel
personnes passion je pense qu'ils ont
comme créer un monde si l'expression
j'en ai créé un monde plus on bride
d'appel à la seconde qui ont une raison
à farah qui n'ont nullement ce qu'on a
créé
longtemps que je pense que dans le fond
le final menchov
ça a mis en lumière justement cette
tendance des médias placé on parlait
même d'américains punition comme encore
le tour pour investir encore plus
poussée finalement québec mais pas la
même game mais ça a mis en lumière les
dysfonctionnements des médisants fait la
recherche constante sensationnaliste et
le fait qu'ils pourquoi il a garni
sans doute parce qu'il y avait tellement
de surexposition médiatique par rapport
aux autres c'est par rapport à hillary
clinton ya quatre ans thé parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'il faisait une
déclaration c'est tellement incroyable
épouvantable qui s'était couvert pilori
des il savait il yal'affaire déclic avec
ses pelouses fait campagne en temps
c'est un vrai n'y fait et c'est
tellement pas politically correct et le
mais ça fait en faire une seule est lui
également vu qu'il ya gagné puisqu'il
n'ya pas une étude qui montre que en
politique c'est la personne souvent tu
vas voir c'est même chose au québec qui
va le plus d'attention médiatique qui
veut avoir une plus grande chance égale
la représentation de succès les
pancartes à chaque poteau de téléphone
sur un sur une route le pti oui pendant
les élections les et comme tout le monde
veut jouer
gameloft tout le monde mais le plus
détaché du titre mais si ça existe chez
moi une dame et électeurs on avait mis
comme un peu moins car tu es quelqu'un
d'autre près et avoir un électeur que ma
vie ben vous n'avez pas vraiment
organiser le voulait fait que
[Rires]
face aux russes
derrière la dette et les porteurs de la
journée parce que tu es déclenché comme
les premiers jours je veux les meilleurs
pas douter une des failles et des
pancartes sur bois aussi les mettons à
l'entrée d'une grande perspective heures
avant l'étape de combos comme canal sur
les anneaux les gens restent stables
avec jean le district le teaser qui nous
on vise selon vie selon mais cela minuit
on est le sait c'est d'ailleurs le nom
de toujours fonctionné comme ça fait à
l'avant scène c'est en parlant de ce
passé qui pille on veut pas ouvrir le
choix
ce cas légers que je t'aime en plus les
gens de woippy s'il voit que t'es plus
présente les eaux tout aussi voir que je
demandais dans les meilleurs endroits
nécessaires moi ça veut jouer dans la
tête des gens font du rab est que son
mieux même chose dans l'immédiat s'il
vous a pris ce quelqu'un c'est la
notoriété et dr il ya une grande partie
des populations qu'ils veulent c'est en
fonction des qui connaît le mieux
houthis les gens suivent pas
nécessairement toutes les enjeux mike au
final caen qui vont se retrouver en
avant bretagne patron thomas et lui gelé
déjà entendu parler d'eux si je t'ai vu
dans la marne était amené à mener d'ici
dit justement l'armée nationale amener
des idées je peux si les projets de loi
ou juste que tu es dès qu'on discute de
promotion des motions des différents
sujets types justement sur les réseaux
sociaux entre autres je me suis maman
d'abord il ya le dessus certains et
certaines motions sur un sujet qui tient
à coeur qui est allé porter haut qu'on a
pas parlé encore là tu m'étonne pas
qu'il ya une couple de semaines j'ai
fait une motion sur les cours
d'éducation dans les écoles c'est un
taux de chômage 10 dans les oeuvres des
fois parce qu'on entendit ont plus vu
quelqu'un ça mais moi ce que j'ai
constaté au fil de mon parcours comme
député partager fit souvent faire des
conférences vendée c'est gênant
je demandais aux étudiants que vous
alerter les élections puis ceux qui
allaient pas voté je leur demandais
pourquoi pas tant un manque d'intérêt
était quand même une grande curiosité
mais ce qui revenait le plus souvent
petit à m'étonner que je m'attendais
quand même avoir une bonne proportion de
jeunes qu'une fille jusqu'à mais je m'en
fous mais finalement c'était plus comme
c'est quoi ce chant pop subtile pour
faire un bon choix comme trop une grande
responsabilité
j'sais pas comment ça marche à politique
et évidemment il y aurait pu aller peut
essayer d'aller chercher un thé mais il
ya des gens qui ont plus tic
on n'est pas tous égaux le dans la vie
puis devant justement des sujets comme
ce qui peut-être que tout le monde que
la curiosité naturelle c'est d'y aller
pisser c'est qu'avec les chacun un
terrible mais je me dis si on veut que
les gens participent au chemin à la
société qui s'intéresse à ce qui se
passe autour d'eux est-ce qu'on peut au
moins donner les outils pour que tout le
monde puisse exercer son rôle de citoyen
parce que c'est tout le monde qui dans
une famille qui nécessairement est
intéressé par la chose publique et qui
va tous les enfants si on ne vous parle
pas de politique
j'ai déjà tu dis jamais pour qui
moi j'étais fatigué je demande à mes
parents les genres distincts des bas
mais sinon mes parents on aurait pu être
vraiment pas sûr quand même non pas ma
marge c'est pour qu'ils votent mon père
j'ai jamais su ce qu'ils m'ont dit oui
mais ils vont répondre de coups de base
dernier sans tabou j'aime la politique
métis pourquoi c'est tabou c'est
pourquoi pourquoi on fait avec
je pense que c'est parce que je pense
que c'est parce que on n'est pas à
l'aise avec les désaccords en général
c'est que c'est comme si j'apprends
qu'ils votent pour un tel prix mougeotte
pour intel ça va être difficile de
réconcilier parce que je pense que c'est
un problème il faut être à guîtres des
aiguilles comme on dit et je pense que
qui s'est juste 500 parler mais j'ai
comme l'impression que on a un problème
avec les conflits c'est comme ça vient
rapidement tu étais je suis pas dans
l'opinion qu'on aide la personne aura
plutôt que juste comme fabre n'est pas
d'accord là-dessus pita titre tient
maintenant je comprends maintenant je le
comprendrais vraiment mais je la
comprends vraiment plus mettant dans un
contexte comme aux états unis où est-ce
que c'est eux c'est assez c'est quoi le
moule c'est assez bizarre comme comme
que ce soit en côté ou l'autre puis les
deux côtés sont en désaccord sauf que
ici maintenant au québec
oui les partis ont des lignes pillant le
plus à gauche un peu plus à droite mais
on s'attaque si tout ce vote pour un
parti de mot pour un autre
on doit s'entendre sur ben au centre on
est vraiment et toutes les parties
mettant évidemment certains partis plus
obscurs qu'on connaît moins les quatre
principaux partis ainsi que des armes et
ont su tout souvent pour la caq puis
mots pour le pq puis le on est on est
franchie si comme tu as pu le 11 ans
rejoint comment est-ce qu'on se sépare
mais peut-être ça on n'a pas
nécessairement d'outils pour est temps
de parler beaucoup de comment créer des
dialogues
des espaces et bienveillant mais qu'on
peut justement tu es être en désaccord
mais était-ce arrive à lui l'un l'autre
je pense que c'est dans l'addiction
comme ce qu'est vraiment on peut changer
d'une normalité fait de changer 2006
quand même bien voyons des gens partent
clairement peu sympa reproché d'avoir
déclaré que dix ans à 2002 ouai mais
peut-être que c'est pas la même c'est
tellement exactement la même fonction
que depuis 20 ans et autant au contraire
ça va être une bonne chose
après faut qu'on ait les outils pour
justement québec comment est ce qu'on
est capable d'avoir ce dialogue lors
d'un petit boulot dans le respecter on
ne peut on apprend que ça à l'école il
ya des endroits dans le monde ce qu'il
veut vraiment y avoir un apprentissage
du débat et ne serait-ce que de
l'oratoire en général mérogis de la
rediscussion oudin et comme un faire
valoir des arbitres et de
l'argumentation
ou pis moi ce que je considère le plus
important qui manque vraiment à laraque
cissé qui a pas d'éducation citoyenne et
politique et on n'apprend pas à l'école
comment fonctionne un petit team
comment ça fonctionne les élections à
quoi ça sert un député ou un millier de
façon générale mais je connais des
boissons j'ai appris comme un cours de
boxe organisation je m'estime temps de
parler souvent les canadiens comme le
panda star
sauf que c'est anormal alors que c'est
tellement un fondamental qu'on est pas
des notions le pied c'est ce qui m'avait
un peu sauté aux yeux et aux oreilles
quand j'entendais justement les jeunes
on attend dé moi je vais pas voter parce
que je peux surtout je trouve et c'est
parti trop comme une grosse
responsabilité je peux prêt à faire un
choix parce que j'ai pas les
informations sont au courant c'est
important oui mais ils n'ont pas les
quelques manques quelque chose comme
société sont capables de donner ses
titulaires aux jeunes c'est pour en
faire un trou dans un sympathique ont
commencé à discuter le 10 février
il peut y avoir ils veulent en fait
mettre sur pied un cours d'éducation à
la citoyenneté
mais le bon avec la pandémie
s'assemblent et or s'est effectuée comme
et on mangeait toujours une motion pour
que ça soit dès l'année prochaine
qu'ils commencèrent à médecins à mettre
en place a été acceptée mais non on va
voir les quand on fait ce genre de copie
ce sont là des choses symboliques
quand c'est accepter qu est ce que je
suis ça a été accepté mais votez oui oui
je connaissais déjà et pas non mais
c'est quoi les étapes après après ça
nous c'est les députés qui fait ont par
exemple voté une motion à faire le suivi
auprès du gouvernement fait que de voir
comment comment ça se passe et c'est un
engagement qui est simple laissez jamais
un engagement qui est jamais ils ont
lutté mais en même temps c'est sûr que
quand le gouvernement accepte d'appui
des tas tant que parent à ce titre il
fasse sa vie parce qu'après que ça que
ça soit moi qu'au milieu que ça soit les
médias tout le monde pour réduire à
venir mais pourquoi avoir le bac général
et promesses sont tenues le ton général
mais ces méthodes justement la motion
que j'avais faite sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les algorithmes
on n'a pas le pouvoir de le faire au
québec enfin c'était plus une demande
pour le gouvernement fédéral
et après nous pouvoir peuvent quand même
limité le nom
dans certains secteurs affectés moi je
peux bien au gouvernement du québec qui
avez vous fait le suivi était au
gouvernement à ottawa mais après ça
repose quand même ce serait factice tard
ça dépend aussi de leurs marges d'action
mais des fois il ya vraiment des choses
très concrètes qui vont découler de
certaines propositions qu'on peut faire
et comme j'avais fait je pense qu'en
décembre dernier une motion pour que les
produits du géant féminin soit
accessible gratuitement dans toutes les
écoles du québec
c'est ça a été accepté et dans les
semaines qui ont suivi et j'ai eu
vraiment des contacts directs avec le
conseil du statut de la femme qui fait
des études en ce moment sur le sujet
puis ont commencé à les faire grâce à la
motion quelques uns des actions sur
l'a16 a des fois c'est concret c'est le
fun c'est gratifiant de voir que ça peut
vraiment le déboucher sur quelque chose
mais c'est pas la magie nous avons
vraiment valorisant de la motion de
thermique quand tu vois que dans le
concret vraiment ça fait une différence
lundi parce que il ya une vision qui
j'imagine que peut-être les jeunes l'ont
plus quitté
c'est un peu petit pétard de nuages mais
c'est comme ça pour tout la même affaire
pitié mais la politique c'est vraiment
le team et ont amené ce ok on le fait au
plus dans les écoles y en a cessé ses
six direct non c'est vrai tout à fait
éteinte d'un loyer moi je pense qu'elle
a perdu secte et moi même je suis très
critique même si j'en fais maintenant
c'est un formidable moyen de changer les
choses moi je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de neuf qui il faut
redonner ses lettres de noblesse à la
politique ça prend du bon temps
politiques cip des gens qui vont réussir
à changer les choses
à presque toute façon aussi de changer
la société que d'être élu mais
nécessairement on est quand même le ou
streaming grandes décisions
maintenant c'est sûr que quand même un
gros déséquilibre de pouvoir entre les
élus dans l'opposition vers ce
gouvernement puis encore plus ceux qui
font particulier l'exécutif
le conseil des ministres puis je dirais
même encore le pouvoir dans notre
système est vraiment très mainstream
unis
mais ministére hâtivement limiter leur
pouvoir quand tu regardes tu étais comme
moi il n'y a pas grand monde qui on tend
une grande influence dans les décisions
t moi je suis bien contente justement
quand je vois certains de mes
propositions qui font leur chemin comme
celle là mais quand même quand je
regarde un peu de recul
c'est quand même fou tu fais quand même
partie des 125 personnes il y à
l'assemblée nationale quand même au
pouvoir est relativement restreint oui
été l'avantagé que j'ai une tribune je
peux amener quand même certaines des
mêmes qui sont pas adoptées must be ou
quand on peut retenu par le gouvernement
je pense que j'ai fait quand même
avancer parce que ça me permet d'en
parler dans les médias la société en
général persistant chez puis
éventuellement enfin petit peu le puits
on s'en rapproche peut-être mais c'est
quand même un petit spot direct comme
accents la personne qui est vraiment une
possibilité d'agir direct sur mais les
champs de compétence du québec s'est
promené dans ce cas même si un ministre
est une star mais en dépit pour laquelle
et travaille très fort peu et c'est
beaucoup c'est prime mais c'est pas
d'accord ou la première ministre
j'ai beaucoup de pouvoir cette année
comme thème monarchique en fait tu es le
roi ou la reine avait tous les pouvoirs
aujourd'hui on est quand même dans une
monarchie parlementaire
même constat n'est elle donc c'est un
peu quand analyse les pouvoirs du
premier ministre un peu comme si on
avait délégué reward du monarque
après match et ça ça serait pas si ça
serait pas le système
maintenant que tu es tout prix imposer
implanter le système idéal ça serait
possible demain matin dans cette règle
serait posté hier est commun je ferai
comme un mix de plusieurs systèmes qui
existent dans le monde mettait déjà un
système où on pense t paraît comme c'est
le cas ailleurs le tout juste en france
l exécutif et législatif sont séparés
depuis quand je dis c'est que le conseil
des ministres nommés et non peut il
utiliser des députés qui font partie du
conseil des ministres le style vraiment
et qui ont le pouvoir d'initiative
législative vraiment fait tellement
comme député jean déposer des projets de
loi qui seront jcb qu hitler
j'amène des idées visiteurs que c'est
important de le faire puis je trouve tes
je trouve sympa je suis certaine que ça
fait avancer les idées aussi l'emballage
de ces pays mettait un peu de plongée ce
ticket le gouvernement va pas ça serait
très étonnant tout cas qu'il ait raté
pratiquement jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire qu'un gouvernement décide
d'adopter un projet de loi d'un député
de l'opposition met donc on peut faire
des modifications au projet de loi du
gouvernement on peut déposer des projets
de loi
mais c'est quand même un pouvoir qui va
rester dans les mains selon des
ministres en tout cas ailleurs dans le
monde
c'était vraiment et paris ce sont les
députés peu importe que ce soit un
député du parti au pouvoir ou de
l'opposition qui peuvent déposer des
projets de loi après c'est sûr qu'ils
aient tout en question majorité où tout
ça mais quand même il équilibre des
forces est un peu différente quand tu
sais pas vraiment le tout ce qui est
conseillé ministre russe est élu député
ceux qui travaillent lillois donc c'est
déjà je pense que ce serait quelque
chose d'important qui est aussi de
pouvoir travailler plus en collaboration
entre élus le nous on est vraiment dans
un système moins ce que c'est le
gouvernement qui est le pouvoir surtout
quand il est majoritaire c'est
pratiquement un chèque en blanc
vers 6 l'opposition justement kim selon
le dicton rôle important dans la
démocratie mais le pouvoir est très très
limitée une tendance alors que par
exemple dans beaucoup de pays dont on
doute on ne repense quand ma vie par
exemple 20 millions des systèmes
politiques ou est ce qu'il ya vraiment
des coalitions de partis qui vont
gouverner
donc il ya un travail constant avec des
élus de plusieurs formations politiques
ça te forces à aller au delà de juste la
partisanerie pneus juste travailler avec
les gens de ton équipe ça t'oblige à
mesure on va faire les alliances avec
les autres des plus représentatifs à
celui d un éventail plus large d'idées
de la société aussi mais pour pour y
arriver ça sonnerait change de système
faudrait changer le mode de scrutin et
parquet tout est basé justement serait
le fils d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
députés on a un système qui favorise une
maman j'ai retardé donc on n'a pas la
culture de travailler en coalition entre
les partis politiques en collaboration
fait un travail de longue haleine
il faudrait partir moi je vais prendre
le temps de partir sur une page blanche
de l'écrit un nouveau système politique
soit vraiment à notre image sont devenus
un pays ce serait une possibilité montre
que c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
souverainiste et pasquet
je mets d'ivoire ça donnerait vraiment
un bon point de départ puis on pourrait
vraiment s'inspirer l'esquissé mieux à
l'international puis parlant d'eux
parlant d'élection parlant de scrutin tu
te présenter à la mairie de longueuil où
tu vas te présenter voilà pourquoi te
décider parce qu'elle était la
motivation de gm présenté c'est cet
automne donc un petit peu moins d'estimé
maintenant pourquoi j'ai choisi de faire
c'est bien ce que dans mon travail de
député ce qui est je dit j'adore cette à
l'assemblée nationale c'est mais ce que
je préfère je viens justement ce que les
effets plus concret puis dans nos
circonscriptions les députés et on a
vraiment l'intention d'agir très
localement d'aider d'accompagner les
écoles accompagnés les organismes ce
pied ce je trouve que c'est très
stressée vraiment ça nous porte le
commis lui parce qu'on voit la
différence qu'on est capable de faire
à ce moment la fac c'est là que j'ai
comme allumer que la politique de
proximité c'était vraiment quelque chose
qui me parlait encore plus depuis que je
me suis dit mais pourquoi poté avec les
années j'ai appris à découvrir la
politique municipale qui est vraiment
moins connus parce qu'on en parle moins
dans les médias lui mais pourtant c'est
souvent ce qui va voir l'effet le plus
direct dans la vie des gens et les
services qu'on va consommer au quotidien
c'est souvent des services qui viennent
qui viennent la ville
donc ça fait partie de ma réflexion
s'est ces derniers mois puis je mens je
savais que j'allais pas me représenter
aux prochaines élections québécoises
aussi donc je me suis dit mais pourquoi
petit je pense que j'ai le goût de
relever ce défi là c'est certain que de
pouvoir avoir l'occasion d'être mairesse
de longueuil par exemple mais ça me
permettrait de réaliser des projets
vraiment concret d'avoir si la
possibilité légale du projet le jt de
tlm heures les mères est un peu
l'équivalent du pr news québec mais dans
la ville la dre bon avec ton équipe tu
peux regarder ni projet est le pouvoir
décisionnel fait que c'est sûr que je
cacherai pas que je trouve que c'est
et comme effet appris que je reviens pas
d'avoir serait sûrement ma société près
le calq c'est avec la pandémie si je
trouve qu'on a réalisé davantage c'est
ce qui nous entoure
on y rester chez nous dans nos quartiers
il ya comme une des raisons de cette
date et 6 et ont bâti ou question est
évident si puis je pense y avait
vraiment quelque chose à faire est de
bâtir la petite justement on a parlé
tantôt de l'économie locale c'est
vraiment laid des commerces de proximité
puis il semble que il ya comme une
espèce de mouvement comme ça à
l'international qui est un retour vers
les communautés très locales qui dans le
fond pour agir sur les grands dangers de
société éthique on parle d'environnement
dont on a parlé de confiance mais je
pense que c'était plus facile d'agir
plus proche de nous pour après avoir une
influence plus grande à d'autres
qualités ça ça peut partir de très petit
mais qu'au final c'est l'ensemble des
gestes comme ça a dit yannick vantait
d'avoir plus d'influencé que d'attendre
pendant 20 ans de réforme une réforme
j'aurais d'une machine le pendant exact
c'est plus facile à faire bouger c'est
plus flexible donc c'est en europe ça
fait des années que justement tous les
mouvements écologistes par exemple
beaucoup investi les municipalités au
québec ça commence je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant parquet c'est par le sap
astéries les infrastructures center est
lié
c'est le verdissement la lutte contre
les îlots de chaleur humaine les gestes
et les transports le développement des
transports collectifs par l'éminente et
après ça va être lancée par le
gouvernement les mais le déploiement
l'effet que les citoyens vont les
utiliser facebook où elle élimine east
ltd qui vont pouvoir marquer le pôle
actif acfo avoir suspendu bonne personne
qui partage ses convictions le à des
postes clés dans les municipalités à
faire le québec à travers le monde
j'ai le goût de prendre part à ce
changement
j'imagine que par le changement
j'imagine parce que les choses que tu
veux changer c'est quoi mettons en ce
moment qui à longueuil qui pour toi qui
cloche que tu voudrais améliorer changé
ni que l écoute seul
il que c'était peut-être un futur
électeur mais falloir que tu le
convaincre la grosse problématique en
fait connaissait tant d'années à
l'ambiance était vraiment qu au niveau
du climat politique de santé branche de
l'ong met donc voyez une et d'un grand
conflit à petit les pieds pas sur des
idéologies vraiment des conflits
personnels et dans sa mémoire c'est
souvent c'est malheureusement en
politique surtout en parle peu justement
souvent les stars qui ont été vues plus
comme des abstractions pas tendre comme
des vecteurs de changement comme vous
dès maintenant c'est qu'on perd est
vraiment comme un gouvernement de
proximité comme je dis il ya comme
tonnes grands enjeux internationaux sur
lesquels on peut agir de façon très
locale
on veut de plus en plus vers ce thème
est techniquement c'est plus comme des
gares des clochers août et ne sera que
nous on a connu beaucoup d'argent à
aston villa comme son charme non c est
quand même plusieurs années
ça touche beaucoup de milieux municipal
factice a contribué à donner une très
mauvaise presse non plus avec certaines
chicane
nous on en a connu notre lot la longue
et c'est dans nos amis faites moi c'est
sûr que puisque je travaille beaucoup
comme des [ __ ] et à trouver des façons
dans la politique différemment à
rétablir la confiance de ses romans dont
j'étais qui m'interpelle puisse jamais
se mettre en place mais façon
d'impliquer davantage seulement les
citoyens dans la prise des décisions et
de les consulter davantage parce
qu'après tout nous à chaque fois audrey
que comme une décision dans une station
à longué ça éclate comment un scandale
télé mais jenson for chip
mais ça je pense que ça parle beaucoup
justement du manque de commutation avec
la population du monde mais je ne suis
pas nécessairement comment les décisions
sont prises des décisions prises
derrière les portes closes dans jamais
ça me rend plus de 30 dollars hors exact
est de bâtir un modèle politique
différence c'est quelque chose qui me
parlent beaucoup et puis je me dis ça
c'est possible de le faire à une échelle
d'une ville qui c'est sûr que je cache
pas que je reste après que sa femme lui
dit que c'est une influence aussi à un
plus grand était selon qui il est et je
me sens tout riche de ranger tout
partagé par leur lait puis je suis sûr
qu'on va pouvoir faire un petit mot là
dessus mais sinon c'est ce qu'a fait la
pandémie a exacerbé ou s'il est le lien
quand on parle de l'aide
en passant c'est l'environnement il ya
plein de choses qu'on est capable de
faire la qualité de vie est justement la
qualité des quartiers c'est à développer
le sentiment d'appartenance et nous
c'est sûr qu'il ya beaucoup
d'immigration à longueuil s'effectue
d'abord terrain vivre ensemble aussi
qu'il soit sain d'endeavour de là on a
déjà beaucoup de mixité sociale c'est ce
qui fait nos forces dans des longues et
populaire c'est dans les quartiers il va
avoir oui ça peut sembler un peu
éclectique parce que tu vois maison
familiale à présent un bloc a précisé il
ya vraiment différents types
d'habitation mais je pense que c'est ça
fait notre force actuelle le vivre
ensemble je t'avais de police si
extraordinaire je peux savez la chance
maintenant une bonne suggestion invités
à faire de la rochère de peines ses
chaussettes liste des suggestions kanner
supplier sixième round des sessions
partie est vraiment incroyable a été
justement lui je pense que tu si on a
tellement parlé des modèles de peut voir
police dans l'aisne dans la dernière
année
est-ce qui en a injustement qui réussit
bien je t'adresse de police comme une
fois prêtre bugeaud viennent dialoguer
texas pas on est justement des belles
force com s'est montré qu'il ya quand
même une espèce de préjugés qui
ressemble à un long tour de notre ville
sont autant longue et j'ai pas il ya
encore une tête une connotation plus
péjoratif quand on parle de notre vie
affective de mise et de rétablir la
fierté non seulement des habitants
médical et les gens à l'extérieur du
québec à l'extérieur pendant de longues
et et vous à notre ville comme un pôle
comme étant attractive sur un lieu
d'innovation un lieu vous risquez je
travaillais ta place pour les jeunes
c'est parti doucement mais les jeunes a
longuement jusqu'à aller à montréal
la majorité fait comment on peut avoir
de la rétention aussi de notre peuple à
sion pour qu'ils aient le goût de
travailler chez nous puis donc décrit
une espèce d'atmosphère qui va permettre
d'avoir de la fierté mais pas pour juste
une classe de population mais vraiment
pour l'ensemble toutes présentes au fond
du nouveau parti ses enfants mais
exactement qui formation une formation
politique c'est comme ça qu'ils se
perfectionnent présente avec une avec
une équipe va justement témoin parce que
j'ai une vision différente péta des
partis politiques dits star est en
partie terrestre
il ya pas d jamais obligé moi quelqu'un
a voté contre y compris qu santé dans
même si les membres de la formation
belge est vraiment levé sur le consensus
et les délibérations avec certitude a
montré qu un parti mais il ya peut-être
trop juste par un modèle s'est pas fait
à démontrer c'étaient d'autres exemples
lesquels vont apporter à ce que tu as
une idée du de l'appui temps à ce moment
dans la population de longueuil où bat y
avait eu un sondage haut débit métier ce
n'est pas l'image telle on est comme
maintenant plus une idée de qui vont
avec les candidats à la mairie on
explique je suis maintenant comme
beaucoup surtout que c'est moche
un des défis siège me donne c'est
d'essayer d'augmenter le taux de
participation que parce que ce fc
famille l'éclat bernard et l'expérience
a été 33 % des gens d un électeur sur
trois
comment on est la cinquième plus grande
ville du québec t pour moi ça pose des
questions le problème c'est les gens
sont interpellés
manifestement il ya du travail énorme à
faire d'un groupe d'âge en particulier
qui votent pas les jeunes et j'aime ses
34 dans le professorat pour inviter les
gens à aller voter' donc de longueuil
dalila des podcasts qui vise les autres
avec un public
elle entre en france mais sérieusement
j'ai j'ose croire aux côtés d'un du
moins par ma présence par le fait aussi
tiquer primo mon équipe va vraiment
c'était quelque chose de super important
pour moi est très présent tentés de
l'ong vivent des gens de tous les âges
lors la partie il voir des gens je
demande de plusieurs origines
différentes parce que c'est sa longue et
cheap mais en ce moment on regarde le
côté de vienne que je donne un exemple
de longueil parce que fait ma vie elle
mais c'est un peu comme ça à travers le
québec fait ce travail souvent un seul
modèle et d'hommes plus vieux blancs
c'est eux qui votent enfants les ben
c'est lui the bus 13 ans et représente
près ce qui va tuer l'esprit est à
[ __ ] divers avantages mais pourquoi
encore l'été passe moi j'entends souvent
l'est déjà mais qui essaye de donner des
conseils fait partie y en a beaucoup et
on est ravi c'est un oubli pollet s'est
laissé les hommes plus vieux
l'équivalent d'une année qui sont les
propriétaires les locataires les jeunes
le soir c'est qu'ils n'ont plus que je
me faisais lui les personnes qui sont
tous l'immigration boeuf
ok mais pourquoi est ce que ces gens là
je vais peut-être c'est un peu parce
qu'ils manquent de représentation il ya
près d un équipement qui d'ailleurs
quelque chose que j'avais les jeunes
comme dany qui montré qu est le facteur
qui influence est plus les jeunes à
voter c'était l'effet d'avoir les jeunes
qui présentent aux élections oui 100 %
pour sa fac ci s'applique aux jeunes ça
s'applique à toutes les tranches de la
population j'imagine c'est quelqu'un qui
donne à ces deux monarques visible si à
peine 1h10 visibles comme les hawks
présente montech
ça va être moins portés à astrakhan est
c'est le phénomène du modèle est
tellement important dans toutes les
sphères l'adresse ip dont la politique
donc certes que j'ai travaillé fort sur
le recrutement pour que ce soit le coeur
que l'on puisse avoir un compte et
devient la langue et qui reflète
réellement la population parce qu'en ce
moment sur ce style
élu il ya quatre femmes sur 16 je pense
qu'il ya un milieu avec 41 morts puis y
at il un moyen de plus 55 puis auquel
personne 2009 alors que la langue et ses
important si je me dis ça va pas régler
tout et je dis pas que tu te laisses tes
personnes vont aller voter aux élections
le 7 novembre mais un petit mètre et non
seulement les chances d'un côté pour
intéresser ces gens l'aiment et c'est
aussi des valeurs qui sont importantes
fondamentalement t même s'ils savaient
pas d'influencé sur les votes je le
ferai parce que c'est important puisque
même si c'est peut-être maintenant que
ça va avoir un effet sur le taux de
participation mais peut-être apprendre
de trois élections duquel il va y avoir
un effet six mois avant de le gagner
évidemment je les fais pour être si je
souhaitais pas être élue le 7 novembre
mais c'est aussi parce que je suis
démocrate je veux t on verra pour
artistes acer finalement une hausse de
participation mais s'il y en a une
moi je trouve que tout le monde est
gagnant si on peut intéresser plus de
gens la politique après ça a été un
débat d'idées justement ces eaux à tout
le monde est de faire son travail pour
convaincre que l'histoire de l'appuyer
mais le fait qu'ils aient aussi peu de
gens du bateau direction de moi ça me
préoccupe puisque pour ce que je sais
faire essayer de faire en sorte de juste
des missiles c'est un politique
municipale je vais départ mais des
initiatives qui vont permettre aux gens
d'être mieux à comprendre puisque c'est
moins couverts je demande dans les mois
et les gens sont peut-être plus
interpellés parce que théoriquement
c'est vraiment la politique vraiment
plus de proximité python plus d'effet
direction du jeu
on dirait que j'avais une vision je sais
que changer dans les dernières années
mais mois initialement je me disais je
croyais pas vraiment là au changement à
petite échelle tu imaginais plus un
changement qui venait d'en haut qui
allait permettre de modifier les choses
pour que ça aille assez vite quand qu'on
est confronté à des enjeux qui arrivent
aussi rapidement et oncle et avec la
crise climatique par exemple que je me
disais si moi je m'achète des pailles en
stainless je fais ma part mais si ça se
repasse et puis puis londres et que les
magasins je réalise que ça sera un peu
ça va être impossible que ça que ça se
passe par un pitbull a que ça passe par
un beau par la politique de proximité ou
comme ont parlé avec jean marc fortier
la culture de proximité juste et comme
ceux qui l'appelaient ou été ou est ce
qu'il étudia québec moi je vais faire
c'est ici puis on va espérer concret
tellement un bon exemple qu'on va
pouvoir faire tout leur ensemble ça
devient rapidement grossi que ça se
multiplient pique ça s'accélère exact ça
accélère que ça prenne un erre d'aller
qui devient exponentiellement rapide ces
puits puis on dirait que vingt dernières
années je sais pas de conversation
conversations seraient que je me suis
mis à y croire plus haut j'ai fait le
même cheminement que toi maman ses
débuts c'est comme quand je t'ai même au
cégep algues vertes et moi je vais
études en classe internationale puisse
imaginer travailler je suis par l'onu ou
quelque chose du genre pied au final tu
vois je t'ai vu j'étais député je me
présente aux municipales tg je réalise
que oui on peut évidemment c'est à même
d'aider idée la plus grande échelle
mais je pense de plus en plus avec sa
passe par une mobilisation au plus
proche des gens j'ai l'impression
peut-être aussi que par comment les
humains on fonctionne que c'est
peut-être comme ça que ça a plus d'
influence dans frontières des fourneaux
des grandes aimez-vous s'adapter aussi à
adapter humaine tout d'abord qu'est-ce
qui est plus propice à avoir un effet
plus rapidement si parce qu'elle est ici
la population dans boy peut même éviter
de servir à temps tout ce qu'on faisait
par rapport aux élus et puis aux
décisions qui sont prises
est ce qui est vraiment quelqu'un qui va
s'intéresser à fait et ce n'est pas un
mouvement la base qui vivent un calvaire
influence après sur les gens qui sont au
pouvoir
la politique approchait s'ajuster le
site mobilisation psy un changement ddd
des valeurs ou des comportements chez
les individus apprécié le politique ce
qui veut aussi desservir ces gens lui
plaire à ces gens là donc il peut y
avoir un changement aussi un changement
bonne ouais
maintenant que maintenant qu'ils des
jeunes qui nous écoutent qui sont de 18
34 qu'ils veulent
s'impliquer politiquement pas
nécessairement à longueuil mais juste ce
site comprendre mieux essayer de dire
parce que parce que je sais que toi
mettons là la diversité en politique ce
que tout est super intéressant super
important skull mans puis comment
comment quelqu'un qui nous écoutent qui
dit moi j'aimerais c'est 6 de faire
changer à faire mais je sais pas par où
commencer je sais pas quoi faire je sais
pas où aller je sais pas qui parle et
qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est parce que je
suis en a plein qui qui qui sont que qui
ont des idées qui ont des envies qui ont
envie de révolution mais qui savent pas
trop quoi faire
c'est vrai on sait pas trop bien
commencer un jour dans ma vie je me suis
avancé adam hall commencer comment parce
que quand tu n'es pas d'un milieu
justement qui paient le prix comment ça
a été parmi d'aminé j'ai fait des
recherches et des événements comme un
exemple rencontré nécessairement des
jantes sa partie pas les événements si
je pense que de bâtir un réseau de
contacts nécessairement mais sinon ici
par exemple
notons que c'est la politique municipale
qui peut intéresser je cherche et ayant
à s'informer à savoir ce qui est des
gens qui se présentent dans notre vie
souvent le maintenant les gens sont
présents sur les réseaux sociaux très
actifs de poche gêne ici pour contacter
des élus et moi j'aime écrire que c'est
moi qui je vais te répondre
personnellement et il y en a plein qui
le font si des gens peuvent pâtir comme
ça puis de peu il fonda l'impression
qu'elles étaient les élus ou canéjan ex
présente en politique c'est parti mais
peut-être moins vite qu'avant
qui fait peur à ce poste parce que on se
fait dire c'est nous on est les
policiers qu'on évite ce sens sont pas
mal tous solistes un peu de crachin
rapprocher plus longue saison mais les
invités du monde le beurre puis la
pension on les avait reçus y viennent
pour qu'ils veulent pas venir genre de
choses là mais si quelqu'un veut
s'impliquer c'est quelqu'un qui va
retourner de bord quelqu'un qui veut
waouh j'aimerais sans les femmes à aller
faire des appels pour toi non et c'est
peut-être une façon si vous trouvez le
management avait pas de casque donc tu
es juste pas à vorey de génie pur comme
à l'été de nous mêmes c'est à les
pousser des portes dans les systèmes for
me contacter et de monter c'est un peu
comme ce qu'on réussit finalement à
faire son chemin pierre a trouvé une
façon de s'impliquer
c'est sûr que ça ça ne tombe peu cheap
surtout encore une fois j'en viens à
part les classes en politique à
l'éducation citoyenne on apprend peu non
plus comment faire de la politique comme
en fait qu en politique comme en même
temps y'a pas non plus une seule manière
tc surkis quelqu'un voudrait s'appuyer
dans un parti peut toujours contacter le
du parti ou dernier le monde partie mais
encore limitée je conseille la plus
vraiment gens de contacter directement
quelqu'un que ce soit un milieu que ce
soit contre aux élections s'ils veulent
avoir une expérience de politique
élective de contribuer matin une
campagne ça peut être quelque chose de
super formateur est intéressant dit
qu'est ce que tu dis à quelqu'un que
s'il ya quelqu'un qui qui se reconnaît
pas pantoute en politique c'est une
minorité visible ou
où je mène une jeune femme quelqu'un qui
se reconnaît pas du tout dans les
modèles que dans les politiciens qui
qu'est ce qu'on dit à ces gens là parce
que pour que ça change la loi qu'à une
meilleure représentation favori en face
le chou c'est la fin mais comment qu'on
brise la chaîne
mais comment briser la chaîne c'est que
ceux qui sont en position de pouvoir
faut qu'il fasse c'est fou que eux ils
fassent démarchage pour changer les
choses et le g genève 10 mois je les
fait l'effort les ti sais pas si sur six
mois vraiment les mois j'ai été surprise
et et j'anticipe rpg comme un crime et
moi pour moi c'est non négociable
j'ai mon équipe il faut que je me trouve
et on a quinze personnes qui vont se
présenter dans les très longues et voir
s'il est ce que je veux d'imagerie au
moins sept femmes sur 15 juillet c'est
tout même plus petit le mans et je veux
au moins deux ex nombre de personnes qui
sont soit des marchés visés soit qu'ils
sont c'est l'immigration de ces petits
gosses et j'ai cessé mon bas rhin puis
oui gentil d'avoir 35 cv ou est plus que
celle des deux super intéressants qui
vont contacter ces dames blanc puisse
pas parce qu'ils sont pas intéressants
c'est juste que eux ils viennent
facilement à nous et il lève la main je
demande sérieusement les gorges et
services it et la fois passé mon équipe
ça a pris même pas 24 heures qui m'avait
répondu tu es une femme c'est plus long
suivante il faut que la rencontre
plusieurs fois et il ya comme une espèce
de la socialisation des jeunes filles la
société fait en sorte qu'on dirait que
les filles ont moins confiance en elle
quatre mois c'est quelque chose que j'ai
constaté un brin de 6 et une plus
difficile je demande de les convaincre
qu'elle ferait un bon travail pendant l
ongtemps de compétentes que les hommes
se sont dits fillon que ça qu'ils disent
par cvc qui ont vraiment rien à ce
qu'ils ont ils n'ont pas une gêne et de
leur parcours bien au contraire biafrais
reçus par mon travail mais sinon tout
est une question de perfectionner de
quelqu'un qui serait meilleur que moi
donc il faut travailler un peu plus fort
puis peut-être compliqué les gens qui
font partie maintenant des minorités
visé justement puisqu'il se voient pas
ils vont pas avoir tendance à lever la
main ou même encore le faut aller nous
fait
tendre la main et montrer ce que j'ai
fait c'est moi j'ai constaté que lorsque
par exemple j'avais annoncé mais une
cantate qui est une jeune femme qui est
né au burkina faso tout après j'ai eu
des messages de femmes de la diversité
qui monte est un moustique gélives
immédiatement puis au final tu te suis
vraiment vraiment content de l'équipe
que je vais avoir ré au total totalement
que ça représente longue et puis peu
importe qu'elle arrive je vais être fier
de l'avoir fait si j'espère que ça veut
ouvrir la porte c'est à d'autres par la
suite que ça va marquer une certaine
comme un saint et et des maxis et qu'il
faut cesser ce genre de leur seront
présentés si j'espère que mon équipe va
crier ou qu'est la majorité d'entre eux
vont être élu mais au moins ce message
là ce sera envahie et puis j'espère que
ça va faire des petits étaient 1
pourrait les prochaines années autant
chez nous qu'ailleurs un coeur à travers
le québec dit je veux plus qu'on voit
c'est un conseil de ville qui est aussi
une forme puis ça vous pour cette
instance politique le comme ça en vaut
pour pour d'autres donc je pense de ces
petits jeux mais très peu la pression de
rené à ta question sur les épaules des
xv à peu mais vraiment mais ceux là qui
ont pouvoir de changer les choses magot
ça vous fait votre responsabilité
c'est plus de travail il sort vraiment
ça m'a pris pas mal plus de marche de
téléphone qu'ils aiment pour porter mon
étude peut-être que si j'avais juste
pris un peu les premiers ennuis
ça empêche pics qu'ils soient bons mais
s'ils conjuguent notre démocratie
représentative le rgo fort toi qui es
trop justement des gens qui vont la
représenter la société
c'est pas juste dire la vérité pour la
liberté ça a un effet concret après sony
décision qu'on prend à part que c'est on
veut arriver à prendre les meilleures
décisions pour nos collectivités une
société c'est important d'avoir des gens
qui ont vécu différentes réalités
sinon il n'y a pas cette sensibilité-là
différents enjeux où on va discuter
quelque chose d'une sauce sur le port
hercule
peut-être qu'on va prendre les choses
avec un recul qui va par la suite avoir
des effets négatifs sur la santé un
groupe de population pense que si on a
une plus grande diversité je demande de
profil mais on y sort de couvrir mettons
plus large puis au style plus que deux
profils différents plus que pratiquer
leur meilleur foisonnement des idées
c'est comme
c'est la créativité aussi que vont
dégager les moeurs des puits donc quand
avoir des retombées positives au final
puisse aussi à plein d'études qui le
monde qui se sert un effet direct sur
même l'actualité des politiques
publiques qui sont votées dans les
gouvernements travers le monde ouais
carrément c'est super et manque même ici
une politique maintenant qu'elle est
conseil d'administration des sociétés
publiques depuis 2006 si je me trompe
pas il ya un parti qui est obligatoire
donc les administrateurs des conseils
dans une station et thierry des études
qui ont montré que les conseils d'un se
rassemblent depuis cette loi le sont
encore plus performant tout parce que
les femmes sont plus intelligentes il ya
des femmes que ça va tomber bien non
c'est parce qu'il ya des profils très
différents - qui s'était statement plus
différents points de vue qui amène
d'édition énergétique en challengeant is
being au bout de près c'est horriblement
plus de gens pour te remettre en
question tombe des recettes plus forte
pour sortir parce que c'est un gros des
personnes qui ont la même époque avec
les mêmes bendjo mêmes référents
culturels
il ya des chances qu'ils étaient un
point de vue réalité mathématique en
fait ce qui est à présent le sommet
tombe du provincial ou municipal le
projet de la souveraineté ou pis toi ta
fibre souverainiste doit la mettre un
peu plus loin dans ta liste de priorités
n'attendent n'ont marqué pour mentir ça
démarrait cesser les convictions qui
m'ont toujours admis en politique puis
même si évidemment le coffre peut
peut-être faire de longues et le pays
enfin longueuil
ça commence à celle front de libération
des juristes à mon plat mais non sans
blague donc été constatées quelque chose
que du foot pour moi plus exact de toute
façon ce sont eux qui étaient on va pas
se cacher aux parents c'est plus
difficile pour le mouvement sur gagner
je pense que comme plus dans le tour il
faut faire comme une réappropriation de
ce projet leur part les citoyens
définition puis donc je pense qu'on est
dans cette phase là que j'y crois plus
je continue d'y participer d'ailleurs
mais et c'est dans un autre hall qui va
être une star qui va est évidemment
distincts de cet engagement sur nice
l'heure parce que je dors j'espère quand
même être là mais reste de tous les
longueuillois peu importe leurs larges
horizons politiques
mais pour moi c'est clair encore une
fois c'est une question de transparence
les gens savent où je loge on a été
apprécié postaux qui veut manger on peut
avoir peur et encore le prénom petit est
même question de peur par rapport à
cette question les mets autre que c'est
pour dire que ça va resté en moi c'est
pas parce que je peux comme à
l'assemblée nationale que ça sera pas un
enjeu sur lequel sait qu'ils vont animer
une somme que je veux continuer
d'intervenir en tant que citoyenne où il
s'était présenté au pq thé de tout ce
qu'on appelle souverainistes pressés ou
de dépendance ou de nespresso
mais j'ai toujours un fender avec des
termes dont tout le monde jeanne est
pendante et ça que je veux que ça soit
le plus rapidement possible pendant que
j'y crois ça serait mieux être un pays
phare pourquoi apens mais en même temps
je peux dire de celles qui traitent
comme équipe avec coûte que coûte
s on ne veut plus on construit on ferme
et on s'était beaucoup activée et nantes
en outre plus de référendum c'est pour
vous consulter la population toutes ces
images dans ce cas on peut faire on peut
prendre le temps de bien faire les
choses que je voudrais pas qu'on qu'on
le fasse la peuple descend cette façon
ça fonctionnerait petit je pense
qu'encore beaucoup un travail
d'éducation par ligne de réappropriation
par les citoyens le changement
nécessairement ce projet l'institut
l'amcp conçu de la même façon entre
devrait pas être présenté la même façon
quand 80 ou comme 1995 pour ses attentes
aux municipales c'est que tu penses que
tu es y est il ya quand même un
changement qui peut être fait dans un
québec qui fait partie du canada noté
parce que je pense que j'imagine que
vraiment pressé c'est comme faire un
pays où plus vite et après se construire
là dessus mais elles sont pour moi comme
temps l'été dans le sens quimper gloire
de manger jasper reste quelques bugs
dans un pays la frappe mon père c'est un
montage du poker rien qui peut changer
je peux dogmatique non plus parce que
y'a plein de choses peuvent changer dans
le québec on est plus limité il ya quand
même des bonnes choses qu'on est capable
qu'on est capable de faire qui n'empêche
pas l'autre parce qu'on améliore le
québec dans le canada que ce serait
quand même pas une meilleure chose
d'avoir d'avoir un pays puisse pas parce
que on travaille sur autre chose d'aussi
qu'on peut il croire travailler à
l'autre aspect du jeu je peux faire la
politique municipale qui en même temps
est une citoyenne souverainiste s'est
engagé non seulement pour ça mais pour
différentes été inscrits par l'autre
est-ce que moment tu veux te présenter
ton madoff ou provincial sera pas
terminé nous devrons non il serait
peut-être en fonction du poids des
doigts même temps c'était faire valider
en même temps ce que peut avoir deux
fonctions électives en même temps c'est
sûr que si j'ai été élu j'ai quitté mes
fonctions mais je peux être content at
il une technique
par contre j'ai décidé comme de demande
à l'assemblée nationale d'avoir comme
l'équivalent d'un congé sans solde
pendant la campagne
ça c'est pas vraiment parce que tu peux
comme ne pas avoir des fonctions divx cc
élective puis je peux pas dire mais je
mets ça de côté donc j'ai quand même
continué à exercer mes fonctions de
député mais j'arrive pas de rémunération
pendant la campagne toral parce que je
les peuples et les citoyens étant donné
que tu permets de vous compliquer si je
le suis déjà mais je vais relais c'est
sûr que ça va peut-être en faire plus
pour ma campagne que c'est mes fonctions
et dans mange avec les doigts d urgence
si je vais toujours comme je dis je vais
porter la responsabilité quand même mais
c'est logiquement c'est sûr que jamais
plus de temps sur ma campagne donc
j'ai vraiment demandé a rassemblé 2
comme drège que tu avant mon salaire se
repose pour arranger c'est la première
fois qu'il me demande comme savoir
comment justement ça a fonctionné chemin
content oui c'est sûr en finissant
comment s'appellent les citoyens
longueuil les longueuillois elle est
longue et oise longueuillois face à la
question vous revenez merci beaucoup
chaque fois merci d'avoir écouté ce
podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe il ya surper tués a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres tué lorsque on
parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre page rituels et le lien
vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui est merci encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin